what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna start Cobra
Kai season five episode one today John
how you doing I am very excited how are
you Andrew how are you I'm doing well
and congratulations you guys on joining
your two dojos would have shouted out
that you got us these shirts if you just
waited geez congratulations
congratulations on congratulating
yourself now the shirts have lost some
meaning because you wanted the praise so
badly you're welcome that's what uh
that's what we do in Cobra Kai we strike
first we don't wait for Chris yeah don't
wait for compliments all right ladies
and gentlemen uh we don't want to talk
for too long on any of these because we
just kind of want to binge this show
since there's so many episodes that are
out and it's already a crazy film
weekend with plenty of content coming
your way but guys subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified
when our reaction for the next episode
of Cobra Kai is up leave a like that
would mean the world to us right about
now also full length Reaction watch
along as we sync up with your own copy
of Cobra Kai available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page lastly
the team at prepper thank you guys for
helping us edit down these highlights
you guys ready Born Ready all right
Angie you better catch all them Easter
eggs every single one I'm a failure
[Music]
within every punch and kick lies
centuries of tradition it has a rich
past and now we want you to become part
of its future
welcome to call for Kai what the [ __ ]
down our dog show is committed to
providing state-of-the-art training
this commercial was expensive we believe
anyone can be a winner
all you need is the right teacher
[Laughter]
it's a new era at Cobra Kai
come join us
We join in
it's crazy some of those camera angles
they got from the tournament for the
commercial
be it one with the water I can find Mrs
Larusso chosen
[Music]
[Laughter]
call me crazy but I thought maybe we'd
be having my ties by the pool not
watching your Okinawan assassin use it
as his training ground
can't wait for Samantha to see him naked
lawsuit you need some help I think you
can help me get to 137. uh you're done
fine giving me some patience
all right there you go and how much you
want to pay for the bag
it's messed up man
this figure a reward might be in order
yeah since we found your bag I'm a real
Mexican and more like discount Thor
oh good here take it off
what you didn't think I'd take all your
money did you really learning that
Miyagi do a way of not striking first
anymore paralyze that guy got some
Choice supplies for the next leg of our
road trip
[Applause]
Mexican Cokes
[Laughter]
I got you a little something to say
welcome to Mexico don't tell me it's
offensive we bought it in Mexico it's
their idea
it's logic I'm shutting down Miyagi do
karate or with everything going on at
Cobra Kai continuing to operate need to
only Target on your backs this Dojo may
be closing
but miyagido lives inside each and every
one of you still Miyagi dough is not a
place
it's up
yet it's Samantha's fault right because
she lost it's definitely 100
all my fault
fight this is
this is Sam I know firsthand that silver
isn't afraid of putting kids in arms
away
and I have to keep all of you out of it
you think it's permanent
definitely definitely only one episode
this season yes
questions
[Music]
so I use the f-bombs on the show I know
where the kid gets off the bus so that's
our first stop and when we get there
what do you plan on doing I'll ask
around if anyone saw me go start with
the Australian guy Terry silver this is
how everyone sees them as some kind of
philanthropist out to save the kids of
the valley
that's why you're here we have to cut
the head off the snake
I can do that cut off one head two more
show hey well
literally cut his head off for cutting
blocking and stabbing and growing
silver may be crazy but he's not dumb
he always thinks two moves ahead you
have to be careful with this guy
more than your son
he must be careful with this guy oh [ __ ]
you're stuck in here with me
[Applause]
I didn't realize there was a camera just
right up in their face when they were
filming the Terry silver money they got
cameras everywhere in town
just all drones circling
you're not telling anyone where you were
going yeah well I know if I told you I
was going you're trying to stop me
because care about you your mom and
grandma left Ecuador to get away from
your dad they probably did it for a good
reason
I I
[Music]
[ __ ] rude beat him up Miguel
you're not gonna ask if I won or lost
how are you making this about you right
now I'm not I oh
there are more important things than
karate Sam yeah
there are
great
he is way better looking
I'm out here trying to fix my mistakes
so I don't have to live with the regret
of making them if you're serious about
making things right you can start by
helping Miguel I know you have your fair
share of regrets when it comes to him
kicking him off the top of that
do a whole flashback of guilt this is
what I was afraid of Cobra Kai's
enlisting kids who have no idea what
they're getting into
um
so I can part three I have seen these
moves before
you have
where
song yeah yeah Kim Sung young South
Korea oh [ __ ] that's a real person I
thought it was just some mumbo jumbo
silver came up with no that's racist
it's very real
my uncle Sato did not speak much of Kim
Sonia
but I know he had much anger towards him
you guys carry this conversation pause
the conversation we carried on the dojo
Kim Sung young was Master of a Tang sudo
but that is not what he taught his
thought was a
controversial what was controversial
about it
I would demonstrate
you will be paralyzed
Kim song is based on Deception
no honor no mercy he could have just
told me
we will use his start against him
how will we do that
I feel like Daniel could have probably
guessed what Terry silver learned from
his master you know just think of the
worst version possible that's all about
aggression
[Music]
McHale's got a brother
eliminate him
fight him
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
don't trust him he's a fierce killer
guy says he thinks he saw Miguel talking
to these Surfers
sorry I dragged you into this Robbie
Johnny and the Surfers that's going to
be fun
good enough
before a kid 17 Ecuadorian
slight build but we're working on that
have you seen it
yeah
he's heading here
oh yeah yeah
oh damn all right Miss what's the scam
give me some bum address try to steal my
wallet we've got five seconds to tell me
which way that kid went I'm gonna take
that surfboard and I'm gonna shove it so
far up your ass your friends are gonna
be surfing you
oh nicely done
do it
damn yeah
I'm not fair
hello
wow
damn yeah oh my God
don't scam my people I was sick
I'm following them this guy carries
himself like a drug lord
thank God that cliche panned out
[Music]
foreign
this is strange
I feel like we've met somewhere before
I'm about to cry sperm count
keep track of my sperm Ranger but
tonight your family okay
okay
come on it's a regular Olive Garden down
here Carmen said he was a very evil man
I could see him but he could have a
super hot stepmom now you're right it
was a mistake to bring you here no it
wasn't
okay I mean some goodness
technically kidnapped and transported a
minor across the border
but we got a good story out of it
hmm
but I'm gonna stay
I'm trying to make things right I want
to help you
at least now we know where we're going x
marks the spot right
all right
all right oh all right let him put his
arm around him this is just the
beginning
we're strangers
but I can tell you we won't be strangers
for long damn my dude's got a nice house
he's evil
Cobra Kai now has more students than
ever before
that means we'll need more senseis
I'm going to pay more than what's
expected
but first
you must prove yourself in The Way of
the Fist
let's see him it's time to see if you're
worthy hey
welcome to COBRA Kai oh
yeah buddy infiltration you knew it oh
so good
clever
clever dude
all right well we got more to watch it's
a super quick thoughts we're gonna
immediately film The Next Episode
um Andrew yes do you want thoughts or
some Easter eggs whatever whatever
Easter eggs are part of the thought all
right well just really quick couple
things I noticed when they had car
trouble with the tire there was car
trouble in Karate Kid Part Two and uh he
blamed Ali with for the brakes or
whatever which was mentioned in uh
season three with Elizabeth Shu boom uh
we also got uh the bonding trip between
Robbie and Johnny they mentioned in
season one how we never had a family
bond a father's uh Sun bonding trip so I
had to make one up now we finally got
one uh we saw Terry silver beating up
some of his lackeys when he was uh just
doing some training we saw that in part
three when uh we saw crease at the
beginning of part three meet Terry
silver in that film so there's a little
reference there and then also we finally
heard uh Master Kim Sung young I mean
they showed the reference back from
Karate Kid Part three so that was cool
to get that back of South Korea so I'm
really curious to see how we're gonna
see that all play out in this because
I'm remember that was just a lot a kind
of a throwaway line but really curious
to see that but in regards to this
episode I loved it was a good
introduction to starting season five I
really like how they harped on the
consequences of what happened at the end
of season four just in terms of Cobra
Kai winning and now Miyagi do shutting
down how it affects everyone and then I
love Miguel's storyline too and
discovering you know who his father is
I'm sure there's going to be some
ulterior mode or you know we're going to
see something different with his father
I mean there's obviously like I know
it's we're seeing a nice it looks like
he's a nice guy but to me it seems like
something else is going to be there but
I think my favorite part of this episode
for sure was Johnny and Robbie I love
seeing I mean the dichotomy of their
relationships so far in the Four Seasons
I mean it's really been understandable
from Robbie's perspective for through
his father you really feel sad and bad
for him but I really love seeing them
together they have such good on-screen
chemistry together you really feel that
father-son Bond and I'm glad to see them
finally rekindling that relationship
yeah yeah
the season didn't feel like the season
starter you know when shows when they do
like a final season and then they do
like a part A Part B like it's part of
the same season yeah there's like a
little bit of a break in between that's
more what this star felt like to me it
didn't feel like brand new season five
it just feels like oh part two of season
four or something like that and I
actually really like that Vibe it feels
like a really strong continuation of
carry on the themes of uh parental
troubles and trying to keep that all
going but of course continuing with this
very specific fight against Terry
Silver's Cobra Kai we still haven't even
checked in with uh John creese yet but I
already feel like we're getting more
substance from Miguel then because I
liked what we got with Miguel last
season but this one episode alone was
like oh this is more of like the Miguel
I've been craving remember that guy was
just a nerd
he is grown I don't even look at him
like a dweeb
that one scene he had with Johnny uh
where he was where we were really
tearing up I mean that was so
emotionally powerful yeah yeah now we're
now we're checking in with him in this
storyline I'm really I'm really liking
it I feel like there's more to come with
that but they're just really this whole
episode is just a good planting of seeds
you know with Samantha what she's going
through
um again challenging the audience to be
a likable character I feel like we've
always been the ones who've liked her
and then she seems to be like such a
divisive character for a lot of people
team Amanda I um Amanda a team Sam Sam
Team all the women in the Larusso house
no Samantha's I have noticed that there
tends to be a discourse around her when
I'm like even like that moment right
there where she was on the phone with
Miguel and that to me it was just it's
kind of like a real thing that would
just happen
it's a real thing of when you get into
an argument and then you feel like why
are you making this about you I'm
calling you about a very specific thing
about me that's just a real thing it
doesn't bother me I don't know a lot of
people seem to have like crap with her
and I don't really have any subscribe or
maybe I've just misread into it but I've
seen really pretty sure I've seen like a
lot like there's definitely there's
definitely crap about her yeah with
Samantha I don't know she's fine to me
and uh I I I'm really enjoying the
Miguel storyline the most uh personally
like whenever we're checking in with her
it feels very refreshing and different
but that knows how to like balance that
storyline with going back to some of
that fun 80s action
um spencil cheese that you love from
Cobra Kai when trying to take down Mr
Silver Johnny Boy
all the things you guys said uh yeah no
everything you said and I love the just
juxtaposition of the Mexican setting
versus everything we have going on at
home I just love the flavor that that
brings I like the scenarios that that
brought up and you know Miguel's sort of
haphazard search for his dad feeling
like you know like he he finds him like
within two people but at the same time
letting it be sort of a difficult
journey within the confines of a half
hour episode and having that initial
fake out interaction like I thought that
was good I love the stuff with Johnny
and uh Robbie and yeah just the whole
chosen thing too like he's so confident
that the outset that I'm like I know
this is gonna become a mental and a
physical and and an everything challenge
you know like a whole challenge of Will
and character for him and yeah that line
up at the end when Terry Silver's
walking down you know addressing the
soon-to-be potential sensei's you get to
that last shoulder on Like It's gotta be
him you know and yeah it's just such a
rewarding but also like horrifying
Prospect because yeah that theme I think
is is going to come heavily into play is
you've got to think like your enemy and
you have to be willing to lower yourself
into the muck and I think that's going
to become very challenging as they go
into the Vipers 10 basically so I
couldn't be happier yeah sorry I was
just going to say I really like to one
last thing for me I really like too how
Daniel's influence in season four really
has you know kind of
really gone on to Johnny because I mean
in that fight at the end when he was
fighting discount Thor and those other
guys I just felt like you know in the
past Johnny would have just struck first
and just fought those guys right away it
was you know kind of like letting them
come to him kind of being more in
defense mode I know Robbie kind of you
know those guys were about to hit him
and Robbie came but again just feels
like the influence of Daniel is really
rubbed off onto Johnny from season four
from their time together in season four
well with training Eagle angan uh evil
eagle Eagle thing and uh and the Miyagi
dough and I really appreciated that
moment that continuity there that was
really awesome so I like that why not to
me that's what I mean by how this just
feels like it's going if it feels like
season four part two yeah
um already like I feel like we had other
than like a couple of different haircuts
no time jumps or anything yeah it's just
continuing directly yeah this feels like
the next episode
and I think that's a really a really
solid start I feel like that if there's
anything that Cobra Kai does
exceptionally well is its consistency
and that which is on Full display here
yeah all right guys well we're just the
very very beginning of the journey as
this show said so uh we're gonna watch
episode two before we go let's do a
patron of the day shout out
hey Fox foxy Fox gonna see you back here
again so we've been looking at people's
names in Urban Dictionary and um I gotta
tell you your name is weird yep
so it says um
Urban dictionaries where it's not mine I
don't want to get canceled
it says a noun a beautiful and
attractive woman she's a stone fox cold
so I'm not saying you're beautiful in a
truck nor am I saying you're the
opposite of that I I'm just saying that
that's what Urban Dictionary is you know
let's find another Urban Dictionary is
hitting on you um okay here's another
one here's another one a hottie wow I
mean every time I've talked about you
I've always met but you know again I'm
not the Urban Dictionary is the one we
didn't write these entries all right um
okay acute orange Sly animal you know
I've always thought you were a bit of an
animal I don't mean like that you were
Sly I've always thought you were like
like the next definition a smart Sly
person like John was doing something
yeah very smart person I understood that
later uh and yeah you're a smart
Sylvester Stallone yeah and hey that's
that's the kind of person we want to
attract it to patreon all right you're
the perfect representation okay here we
go we got a great definition for you
here we go here we go oh yeah um it says
a small animal animal that says
okay
tongue face
what does the fox say about that if you
ask me that we're seeing more towel and
your existence with the Falcon Punch
Falcon Punch I have never gone to know
you better I always knew your sexy hot
Sylvester Stallone ass who's always at
our patreon page I knew that was you as
you especially when you kept asking me
to read the script for the Samaritan I
was like I want to do that nah man that
sounds stupid I already know it's like
two movies fused into one
but we love you fox and others in a
friendly way thank you for being here
[Music]